[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by jaden martel isis
haynesworth and adrian greensmith the
stars of metal lords which is out now on
netflix we'll be talking spoilers about
the film here so watch the film first
how you guys doing today
very good i like the shirt
thank you i appreciate that i like the
hair jaden you always got these like
great hairstyles you're just crushing
and even crush a cool hairstyle here
with uh kevin and what i love about what
you do with the character of kevin is
being a drummer myself i
particularly love the scenes where he's
learning how to play the drums you do
that so well but i'm wondering in those
scenes when you're thinking of how
kevin's going to look physically playing
the drums was there any real drummers in
real life you kind of were inspired by
for that
yeah i was definitely looking at a lot
of uh lars ulrich and
and my my teacher glenn sobel for the
for the appearance and the performative
aspect of drumming and especially
towards the end when he's when he is
performing um
but
i don't know the special thing about
drumming is that it doesn't really
like
the whole point is to not give a [ __ ]
about what you look like and uh i really
like when when i was really into it i
just
nothing else mattered it was about
hitting the right thing with the with
the right amount of energy you know yeah
no that's good advice for me when i drum
now i i think i give a [ __ ] too much
about what i look like so thank you i'm
gonna stop doing that um isis uh people
are gonna love this relationship they've
already seen the film they love this
relationship with emily and kevin but we
can kind of tell when kevin fell for
emily in the film but where do you think
emily fell for kevin was it like the
moment she saw him you think or was it
somewhere else for you
i think it's probably the moment that
she saw him i would say i think
emily's an outsider in school and i
think she sees that kevin is also an
outsider and i think
yeah i think basically for her it
probably started right as soon as he
walks into the classroom and talks to
her like a normal human being does
rather than laughing behind her back or
whatever
yeah i think that's when
that's when it happened
no i like that and i like that you bring
up talking like a normal human being
which i thought was a nice little thing
in between that attraction which is
great point you make and adrian i think
everyone should be talking about i
couldn't stop noticing it but in the
scene where hunter and kevin are in the
car together and they're in this car
chase there's a moment where hunter
grabs kevin's knee for a second so i'm
running through my head is do you think
hunter had any
feelings for kevin or is that just a
knee-jerk reaction in the moment
nature
um very good um i like that right i love
it
um
yeah so i think
when i when i first got the script the
first thing which popped out to me
was that hunter seemed like he was in
love with kevin
but um
i think you know there is it's not
explicitly in the movie there's like
never a scene
where hunter's like oh
like that's what's i got that that makes
sense now i don't think he ever has that
so it's up to the audience to you know
take what they will from it but for me
personally i thought that
the thing driving him was jealousy
uh that emily was giving kevin something
which
which he could which hunter couldn't
give kevin
and also um the other thing driving him
was there was metal inside him which
wanted to rise up and he wasn't letting
it rise up
okay
i love that that yeah and i love that
it's like very subtle this relationship
between them and i love your answer i
think that's just cleared up so much for
me awesome and
jaden you have this huge amount of fan
pages on social media and you're just
this huge level of fame already at this
age you've done such great things is it
still like scary for you or is it like
do you feel like you're a vet now like
you're kind of used to it it's not as
like intimidating oh god i i i well i
don't know if any that's true but thank
you um
no i i
it's so not important to me it's it's
just about um the work and
um
and no it never it never gets any easier
i definitely do not feel like i'm a vet
um
and i'm still
i don't know the special thing about
this job is that you
continue to learn if you're you know if
you're open for it and like
working with adrian and isis i i learned
so much and i saw how hard they worked
and and
how special they were so
i don't know i it was
it's always a learning experience for me
yeah and that's awesome that you really
do sound like a true artist and it shows
in your work so awesome and
uh before i let you guys go isis you've
done the impossible and made cello
playing look really cool so do you plan
on still playing cello after this film
or you kind of this is it i would love
to play cello still i don't have one i
have
uh
something i probably shouldn't talk
about maybe i can talk about it for
spoilers yeah totally yeah i have uh
they sent me the one i
used in the battle of the bands which is
like this oh amazing yeah so hopefully
i'll get to play that at home and yeah
keep on going with it yeah
i love that so you heard it from her
that's really cool a little tidbit there
jayden isis adrian thank you guys for
joining me today and everyone check out
metal lords it's on netflix now and i
hope to talk to you guys in the future
one day
thank you have a good day